BERKELEY CITY COUNCIL DECLARED
THE WORLD IN A QUOTE CLIMATE
EMERGENCY.
THEY CALLED FOR A PUSH TO HALT
ALL CARBON EMISSIONS WORLDWIDE
AND SAID GOVERNMENTS MUST MAKE
EFFORTS TO "HUMANELY STABILIZE
POPULATION.
THAT'S A PHRASE WHICH
ROBESPIERRE WOULD SURELY LOVE.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: SO I'M A PRETTY
LITERAL PERSON, IF THEY SAY
CLIMATE EMERGENCY, THAT SOUNDS
RIGHT TO ME.
SO IF IT'S AN ACTUAL EMERGENCY,
WHY DOES ANYONE IN BERKELEY HAVE
AN AIR CONDITIONER?
I HATE TO SORT OF ACTS THAT
PEOPLE LIVE OUT THEIR PURPORTED
BELIEFS, BUT IF THEY ARE TELLING
THE REST OF US WE NEED TO HAVE
FEWER KIDS, WHY ARE THEY STILL
DRIVING AND USING THE AC?
>> I TOTALLY BELIEVE YOU, TUCKER
BUT I DON'T THINK THEY ARE
TELLING US TO HAVE LESS BABIES.
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE IMPACT
THAT HUMAN BEINGS HAVE ON
ENVIRONMENT IS RELATED TO A LOT
OF STUFF.
NOT JUST THE AMOUNT OF CHILDREN
THAT WE ARE HAVING BUT CARBON
EMISSIONS AND EATING LESS MEAT.
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT WE
CARE ABOUT OUR PLANET BUT IT'S
NOT ABOUT HAVING LESS CHILDREN.
>> Tucker: AND I DON'T THINK
IT IS.
>> ARE WE AGREEING?
>> Tucker: NO, I SAID THE IDEA
IS INSANE AND GROTESQUE AND IT'S
A WINDOW INTO WHAT THIS REALLY
IS, WHICH IS -- >> THEY AREN'T
SAYING IT'S AN EMERGENCY,
EVERYONE HAS STOMACH AND STOP
HAVING BABIES.
>> Tucker: BUT HOLD ON.
IF THEY ARE SAYING AND IT'S AN
EMERGENCY, PRESUMABLY THEY
BELIEVE IT IS.
SO HOW CAN THEY JUSTIFY WRITING
BIASES, HAVING CARS,
REFRIGERATORS, ANY ACTIVITY THAT
ADDS TO THE SUM TOTAL OF CO2
EMISSIONS?
WHY ARE THEY STILL COMMITTING
THESE ACTIVITIES?
WHY SHOULD I LISTEN AND TAKE
ANYONE SERIOUSLY WHO IS DRIVING
A CAR AND SIMULTANEOUSLY TELLING
ME NOT TO HAVE MORE KIDS?
>> I DON'T THINK THEY ARE SAYING
THAT.
IT'S A COMBINATION OF FACTORS.
AND IT'S A COMPLEX ENVIRONMENT.
I THINK IN GENERAL, THE YOUNGER
GENERATION, THE MILLENNIALS, ARE
BECOMING MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY
CAUTIOUS.
I THINK THE TECHNOLOGY IS
CATCHING UP TO THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE ARE BECOMING MORE
CONSCIOUS?
>> Tucker: IF PEOPLE ARE MUCH
POORER BECAUSE THEY ARE DEEPLY
IN STUDENT LOAN DEBT FOR DEGREES
THAT MEAN NOTHING BECAUSE THEY
HAVE BOUGHT INTO THE SYSTEM THAT
IS ESSENTIAL AND DOWN LIKE A
SOCIALLY FRAUDULENT, AND THEY
HAVE NO MONEY.
THEY ARE ENVIRONMENTALLY
CONSCIOUS, BUT THEY ARE POOR.
>> THAT'S ONE PART OF IT, BUT
THERE'S MORE THAN ONE FACTOR
WHEN IT COMES TO CLIMATE CHANGE
AND WHAT WE CAN DO TO REDUCE OUR
IMPACT.
>> Tucker: I AM ACTUALLY IN
FAVOR OF A CLEAN ENVIRONMENT.
SO I WONDER WHY, HAVE YOU
NOTICED THIS?
PLACES THAT SPEND OF THE MOST
ENERGY TELLING THE REST OF US
THAT THE WORLD IS ENDING BECAUSE
OF CLIMATE CHANGE ALSO TEND TO
HAVE THE DIRTY STREETS AND THE
LARGEST NUMBER OF PEOPLE
RELIEVING THEMSELVES ON THE
SIDEWALK, AND THE MOST TRASH?
IF YOU CARE ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT, MAYBE YOU SHOULD
CLEAN UP IN FRONT OF CITY HALL.
DOES THAT OCCUR TO LIBERALS?
>> IT'S NOT JUST LIBERALS THAT
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE, IT'S ALL OF US.
AND I AGREE WITH YOU, WE CAN'T
JUST TALK THE TALK, WE HAVE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH ACTIONS.
YOU CARE ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT
AND MAKING THE WORLD A
CLEANER -- AND CLEARLY I AM FOR
THAT.
>> WE AGREE WITH THAT, WE ALL
WANT TO KEEP THE ENVIRONMENT
CLEANER.
>> Tucker: HAVE YOU BEEN TO
BERKELEY?
NEW YORK CITY?
SAN FRANCISCO?
THERE ARE PEOPLE RELIEVING
THEMSELVES ON THE SIDEWALK AND
THEN WALKING AROUND THEM ARE
ENVIRONMENTALISTS WANTING TO
LECTURE ME ABOUT HOW MANY KIDS I
HAVE.
>> BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY ABOUT WHERE IN THE
WORLD IS MORE POPULATED, IT'S
ABOUT WHO IS USING MORE
RESOURCES.
AND I AGREE WITH YOU THAT WE
HAVE TO DO MUCH BETTER.
>> Tucker: DO YOU AGREE THAT
IF WE ARE GOING TO MAKE THE
WORLD CLEANER, WE COULD START BY
CLEANING UP THE SIDEWALKS?
THEN WE COULD MAYBE GET TO THE
PART ABOUT FIXING THE HOLE IN
THE OZONE LAYER.
>> I DON'T THINK IT CAN BE
EITHER OR, IT'S EVERY DAY.
SPEAK ONE WAY OR THE CITIES WITH
THE MOST OPEN AND AGGRESSIVE
COMMITMENT TO THE ENVIRONMENT
THE DIRTIEST?
WHY IS PORTLAND, OREGON, A
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I'M NOT TALKING SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT PORTLAND, BUT NOT ALL
CITIES THAT ARE SAYING THAT WE
NEED TO DO BETTER ABOUT OUR
ENVIRONMENT ARE FILTHY.
WE ARE YOU GETTING THAT FROM?
>> Tucker: OKAY.
TRACK WITH ME REALLY QUICK JUST
FOR THIS ONE QUESTION.
IF YOU SAY YOU CARE ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT, DO YOU AGREE OR
DISAGREE THAT MAYBE YOU SHOULD
START BY CLEANING UP THE STREET
IN FRONT OF YOUR HOUSE?
>> WHY CAN'T YOU DO BOTH?
DO BOTH.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT SAYING THAT
YOU CAN'T DO BOTH.
BUT WHY IS IT THAT THE PEOPLE
LECTURING ME ABOUT AND THE
ENVIRONMENT LIVE IN ENVIRONMENTS
THAT ARE FILTHY?
>> WE ALL CARE ABOUT THE PLANET
AND CAN DO MORE.
>> Tucker: WE DON'T ALL CARE
ABOUT THE PLANET.
MY HOUSE HAS NOBODY SLEEPING ON
THE FRONT STEP BECAUSE I CARE
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT.